so thanks to those folks
so i'll hand over to dylan in a moment
to tell us all about the workshop
just a few logistics you've discovered
the food and coffee outside that'll be
there for the breaks for lunches you're
on your own
there are lots of options on on and off
campus
please don't bring food and coffee into
the auditorium water is fine but we we
like to try to keep the
these spaces clean
the
at lunch time if you want to leave stuff
in lockers on the far side of the
building there are lockers that work
with with pin codes you can use those
uh so we're working with a hybrid format
uh over zoom and
uh
the um our videographer omid fire is
going to be helping speakers uh hooking
up computers and microphones and so on
um
and
a big thank you also to kelani pendland
who did all the local arrangements for
for this week so thank you
all right
yeah so thanks a lot for uh joining us
for the workshop on multi-agent
reinforcement learning and uh bandit
learning right this is the the last
workshop of learning and games program
so i'll just say a little bit about the
topic and kind of what we have planned
so you know multi-agent reinforcement
learning
you know it's a very rich topic and it's
a it's a topic that's been explored
through uh many different fields over
the years right so uh the foundations
kind of go back to the work of shapley
in the 50s and since then we've seen it
explored throughout you know of course
like game theory and econ but also uh
theoretical computer science and you
know most recently uh ai and machine
learning right both on the empirical
side you know like say in the context of
deep rl
and also even more recently in learning
theory and so you know given all this
excitement the goal of this workshop
it's kind of twofold right so on one
hand we want to highlight the most
exciting recent developments and on the
other hand we want to try to kind of pin
down you know what are the most
important questions and problems to
solve for research going forward
so
we have a i think a pretty interesting
program planned and you know we're lucky
to have
some pretty great speakers kind of with
representation from all of the topics i
was mentioning before and just a few of
the kind of themes and topics we'll
cover you know include like okay so
sample complexity and learning theoretic
guarantees uh computational complexity
communication
coordination
uh connections to say like game theory
and control theory um and also empirical
research right so like deep rl
um okay the the last thing i'll mention
here before we kick it off is just okay
in line with the theme of trying to like
pin down you know open open problems and
questions uh the last session of the day
tomorrow is going to be on open problem
session
so you know if you have uh problems
you're stuck on or that you'd like to
see solves or collaborate on with other
people you know you should come and give
like a little presentation
this is going to be super informal so
you don't have to make slides or
anything you can just give a blackboard
talk and uh yeah i'll make a little like
sign up sheet on the on the whiteboard
after this in case anyone wants to sign
up
okay
i think that's just about everything i
want to say about the workshop so why
don't i go ahead and kick it off and so
to start us off we're really lucky to
have uh sergio hart here he's going to
be telling us about you know calibration
and you know connections to game theory
okay
hello uh
do you hear me
yes yes
yes okay i uh since i i i see only uh
you know the front row of the auditorium
which means i don't see any faces and i
i don't know whether you guys are
following anything i'm saying or not so
feel free to shout and uh and ask or
whatever
you know i wish i could give this this
talk on the blackboard that's my
preferred medium but
well
it doesn't work
okay so uh oh just real quick i'll also
uh monitor the chat for questions in
case this comes up
okay
yeah because i won't be able to
i think so if there is anything you you
just stop me and tell me right
yep sounds good
okay very good
okay so uh
i want to talk to you about cali
calibiti which i guess
that's the reason it's in quotation
marks probably you don't know what it is
you may guess perhaps but we'll see
so first of all this is joint work with
uh well it's not guideline it's dim
foster so it's it's another d foster
yeah
and
here are the papers
by the way the papers and the
presentation you can find them on my
webpage there are links here or just you
know just write my name and go to my web
page and you can if you care about the
this stuff you can find more uh
additional things on my web
okay
so
i don't know how many of you
i gave a talk
when was it
at another workshop
i think was in april beginning of april
or end of march i don't remember exactly
and
in in some sense what i'm talking today
so that was an introduction to
calibration
and
introduction and new approaches and new
ideas and so on so it's not not just it
was not just a review of all stuff it
was new stuff
and i'm in some sense continuing from
there but
since
even if you have the previous time you
probably forgot everything about it
i don't remember what i said anyway so i
i'll do a short recap and then i'll take
it from there so
let's start with what is calibration
okay
so the forecaster says
uh the probability of rain tomorrow is p
okay
uh
now as i
so i i repeat what i what i said in uh
in my previous talk so bear with me if
you have this already
uh once upon a time forecasters would
just say tomorrow there is going to be
rain or tomorrow there is going to be
sun that's it
and of course
they were not very good
and people were really ridiculing them
quite a lot you know weather forecasting
was not something you
was not a profession that people were
proud about to say the least
as i said there are cartoons about
weather forecasting i remember them as a
kid
before any of you were born of course
then at some point uh instead of saying
tomorrow there's going to be rain
forecasters switch to tomorrow there is
a chance of 70
of rain
the chance of rain tomorrow is 70
okay
well and it doesn't rain well it doesn't
rain what do you want i only said
seventy percent i didn't say it's going
to rain for sure so we did rain okay
now the question is uh
can we catch uh such a forecaster uh
in any way or or let's put it in a
better way
is there any meaning to this 70
now of course if it's probability
probability is like the long run
frequency right that's a main
interpretation probability so to check
it we really need a long time
and to see over time whether this is
correct so how do we check it we do the
following thing
the idea is is trivial but it takes some
time you know if you never heard about
it and you think how do i check this 70
what does it mean well here is what it
means let's take all the days when the
forecast was 70
only the days when my forecast was 70
and let's see how many rainy days there
were out of those days when my forecast
was 70
if i'm a good forecaster
uh formally this is called if i'm
calibrated if i'm a calibrated
forecaster then the proportion of rainy
days out of those days when my forecast
was 70 percent should be 70 percent or
close to me
in the long run okay and that should be
true for any 70 yes for 10 20 whatever
forecast i'm using
the long run frequency should equal to
my forecast
then
i'm calibrated okay
now uh
let me start with with a with uh with a
result and let me say as i said i uh
i know nothing about weather forecasting
okay i know nothing about clouds uh
or
any of the physics involved or earth
sciences or anything
but i know some other stuff okay
and with some other stats i can
guarantee that my forecasts are going to
be calibrated
now not just say in the summer in israel
where it never rains and then my
forecast will be zero percent yes
but it's going to be calibrated no
matter what place in the world you want
to put me or no matter how the rain
is generated
even if the rain is generated by a
rainmaker
that as
computer scientists and you guys
computer scientists say is an
adversarial whose only aim in life is to
make me as a forecaster look bad
let's say it doesn't care about anything
else so even against an adversarial
rainmaker i can guarantee that my
forecast will be calibrated okay
now that's a great result due to foster
dean foster and wikibora
in the early 90s probably even earlier
than 94 which they had a very hard time
to publish it because any journal they
sent it to they will get after two weeks
of desk rejection saying
come on you make no assumptions about
the weather this result cannot be true
okay well in the end it was published
because the result is correct and in
fact there is a very neat proof
uh very short proof by the minimax
theorem uh which i
which uh okay i'll say i'm not going to
describe it i'll just say it in one word
suppose that i knew so this is like a
game between the forecaster and the rain
maker
suppose i knew the strategy of the
rainmaker
what does it mean
suppose i knew the mixed strategy of the
rainmaker because the maker of course
may use randomizations if i know the
mixed strategy of the rainmaker then
every day given the history i know what
is the probability that you choose rain
and what is the probability that he will
choose sun
well my focus is going to be that
probability rounded up
to whatever grid i'm working on
so if i know the strategy of the
rainmaker i can obtain calibration
that's quite trivial yes if i know the
probabilities of rain of course i can
get calibrated forecasts the minimax
theorem then says because the whole game
is finite we are talking about the
finite horizon final grid
then the minimax term says there is a
strategy that guarantees calibration no
matter what the rainmaker does okay
very nice result very neat it's in my
view
uh you know it's a beautiful use of the
minimax theorem by the way in computer
science that's what's called the house
house principal okay that's a minimum
story for my month's minimax story
okay
uh
the question is how do you do that
so uh by the way there were lots of
other proofs there was original proof of
ostervora who was like
levine and lots of other proofs of this
result it's such a striking result that
you know people really want to to to
find ways to convince themselves that
it's true
uh
then there is the the work of uh
of myself and andrew muscle uh where we
found
a nice way to guarantee calibration
using black approachability
uh this was simplified further by foster
now when i say foster it's dean foster
yes sorry dylan you are not yet
on the scene uh
so foster is dean foster yeah uh and
then in fact in in our previous paper on
forecast hedging there is an an even
simplest procedure
which
i'm going to describe to you it's so
simple that you know i i want to
describe to you what it is so here it is
so let's draw a picture where on the
horizontal
axis we have the forecast
and on the vertical axis we have the
average frequency of rain okay this is
average action the frequency of rain
okay
so perfect calibration means that
so if i take for example
let's see if i i'm trying some new
technology with my ipad and
something so let's see if it works so
for example i take here oops
well
i think i need something sorry
okay uh
if i take here
oh it does work let's say it takes this
the 20
forecast
then what do i want i want the frequency
of render to be exactly 20
so it means that i should get this point
and the same thing for anything that i'm
using okay
so perfect calibration means that my
graph is going to
to be on this
diagonal
okay
very good
uh
so let's just make life easy i just took
five six different forecasts you know
the 20
just for the picture
and
now i'm at a certain day so there is a
mystery and that history gives me this
graph okay so each dot here represents
the average frequency the frequency of
rain for each one of the six forecasts
you know zero twenty percent forty
percent up to hundred percent okay now
those thoughts are arbitrary i mean
right they come from the past yes i
don't know what they are okay
so here is what i do i have to decide
what to forecast tomorrow so here's what
i do i find two points one above the
diagonal and one below the diagonal
uh
join them
and forecast the exactly the
intersection
how do i forecast the intersection i'm
forecasting those c1 and c2 those two
points is probabilities that on the
average give me exactly the point when
they intersect the diagonal
now how do i know that there is one
point above and one point below
well
the zero percent
okay
uh
it must be that the frequency of rain
is positive right so it must be about
on the other hand
you know what happened here
my
okay
sorry
well
it doesn't seem to be working
the way i expected okay never mind uh
on the other hand for the 100 forecast i
must get the dot which is below the
diagonal okay
so if i start above the diagonal and
below the diagonal then i always must
cross it so i find two adjacent points
when
one is above one is below and i focus
the thing that thing works
so the procedure is extremely simple
okay i just keep this graph and keep
updating every time what happens and
find two points like this
and
and i'm forecasting if c1 and c2 with
the corresponding probabilities so that
the average is exactly the point where
it intersects the diagonal okay
uh
the fact that it works well the proof
takes a little work okay it's not
completely trivial
but the procedure is extremely trivial
can't be any simpler than that okay
very good now let me just show you
before i get into tory and so on uh
some nice pictures that i i took from
the web uh 538.com
that's nate silver's
website so they they publish some
calibration plots which are exactly you
know the horizontal axis what they
forecast on the vertical is what
happened okay you see now you see that
for sports they are pretty well
calibrated almost everything is very
close to the angular
politics a little less you know politics
there is more variance over there
uh
another one is
electionbettingodds.com okay
where again you can see that perfect
calibration is the blue line the
diagonal and what they really got is
something that is not
far away from uh being calibrated now as
i said should we be surprised by that
since there are simple procedures that
guarantee calibration no matter what we
should not be surprised now do they know
anything that we don't know maybe maybe
not i don't know anyway that's uh
just to show you something from the real
life okay
now let's take a let's take a very
simple example no no no i'm uh
uh
moving on okay so that was background so
let's take a very simple example
where uh we just have rain no rain
alternatively on alternating days okay
so day one rain day two no rain sun
basically rain day for no rain assume
that we have such a such an occurrence
okay
and i want to look at two forecasters
here is forecaster number one
he says on day one a hundred percent
chance of rain on day two zero percent
chance of rain basically a hundred
percent chance of rain pay for zero
percent chance of rain i mean this guy
is perfectly calibrated i mean
he exactly tells us what's going to
happen
but let's take another forecaster that
says every day 50 chance of rain is he
calibrated answer yes he's calibrated
now why is he calibrated because when we
look in the long run over all the days
when he said 50
which is all the days
half of them were rain and half of them
were not rain so the frequency of rain
in the days when he said 50
was indeed 50
so he's calibrated
now clearly f1 and f2 f1 is very useful
f2 is not very useful or much less
useful okay it really doesn't tell us
anything just as a long run frequency
okay and again it works because in this
example we had this 50 long run
frequency which doesn't have to happen
in general okay so calibration for both
of them was zero the calibration score i
mean yes say calibration i mean the
calibration score was zero for most of
them but
but clearly f1 is a good forecaster f2
not so good
how can we capture that
so here is a is a neat way to capture it
calibration essentially
is a beaming operation beaning means
taking things and putting them in beans
what are the beans the beans are the
different forecasts so for f1 we have
two beans we have the 100 bean and the
zero percent b
for f two we have just one b the fifty
percent b
so f two takes all the days and puts
them in one b the fifty percent b
and that beam is okay the average in the
b is fifty percent everything okay
f1 takes all the days and puts them into
separate beads the other days when there
was rain they go into 100 beam the even
days when there was no rain they're
going to 0
okay
now what's the difference the difference
is the variance inside the beans for f1
the beans have no variance all the days
in the 100 bean are the same
rain
all the days in the zero percent bean
are the same no rain
f2
the days that are in the 50 percent
being half of them are rain half of them
are no rain so there is a big variance
inside the beam so the inside beam
variance the in beam variance is 0 for
f1 and it's a quarter one half squared
yes because uh
zero minus
fifty percent or one minus fifty percent
is one half yes so the variance is one
quarter which is big it's the biggest
variance that you can get for for zero
one random variables of course
so for f1 the input variance is zero
for f2 the input variance is a quarter
okay
so uh let me just introduce some
notations again
because i want to make things clear
even if you don't follow you should be
able to follow even without the notation
but just
you know when i hear a talk i always
like to make sure that uh
that i follow exactly what the speaker
wants
so notations are sometimes useful so
let's call at the action at time t which
is rain or no rain
but by the way it could be something
more general this could
work in an arbitrary euclidean space
doesn't have to be to be zero one
doesn't have to be r1 can be anything
okay
and the forecaster times c at time t we
call it c of t
and
then
when you take
the forecast x
a bar of x
is the average
uh
of the actions in those periods where
the forecast was x so if the actions are
just zero and one that's a frequency of
one the frequency of ray okay and then
of course we have we set up a capital t
which is our horizon
and
[Music]
it's it's underlying all the notation
here so the capital t i'm not going to
put it as a subscript but everything has
a substitute capital d okay it's the
horizon or as it changes then of course
everything changes so a bar of x is the
average action when the forecast was x
so
if you want the formula here is a
formula
okay but of course uh
you don't have to to i mean everybody
knows how to make averages
and what's the calibration score well
it's the average distance between
forecast
and the average action
for that forecast okay so if you want
the formula here is the formula okay so
look at each forecast and you see how
far it is from the average of the b okay
and you do it at time capital t remember
okay so you saw the formula
then
we have another score
which is the variance inside the bs this
is called the refinement score
okay so we're going to call it r or r
sub t so it's the average valence inside
the beams you want to see a formula here
is a formula you are just looking for
each uh at the distance between
what happened on day d the action on the
18
and
the average in that b
okay and it takes squares you know like
in statistics you always like do
variances and things with uh with the l2
norm by the way it doesn't matter which
norm you use all the nodes are
equivalent but it's convenient to work
with the the l2 node okay so that's a
refinement score okay
now there's another score which is well
known it's a bryoscope briar was a
mythologist
and he gave the following score he said
let's look at the distance between the
forecast and what happened so you look
at forecast which is ct action which is
80 and let's look at the at the average
distance between 80 and cd okay
and that's a prime score
now here is something that
there's also no statistics will not be
surprised
but it does how there is a beautiful
decomposition of the brighter score
into the sum of the refinement score and
the calibration score okay
now by the way there are many various
there are other decompositions of the
branch scores but that that's one which
i think is very useful
and uh
[Music]
so the branch score is the sum of the
refinement and the calibration score
okay you want the proof the proof is is
very easy it's uh it's just a famous
formula that when you want to know what
the expected square distance is it's the
variance plus the distance of the
expectation from that constant square
okay i hope that everybody saw this so
it's just this formula okay
never mind but
in a sense the refinements column the
calibration is called orthogonal okay
one measures the variance inside the
beans the other measures how far away
are the beans from the the what you said
is calibration score it's called as
forecast sorry what you said is forecast
to the average of the b okay
so let's go back to our example uh where
we said calibration is zero in both
cases and the in bin variance is zero
and one quarter so now i can write it as
k equals zero for both of them r being
zero and one quarter and so the prior
score is zero and one quarter okay
so now
as you said f1 is an expert f2 is you
know i would call him an expert but you
know you can still
call whatever you want but if you want
to check real expertise i mean
the the point is that you should not do
it with the calibration score because
both f1 and f2 are going to pass the
calibration score and as i said i can
pass the calibration score without
knowing anything about whether anybody
can pass anybody in the audience can
pass in the score now that you know the
trick how to do it okay
so so calibration is not the way that
you identify experts okay the way to
identify us experts you should look at
the prior score okay
that's that's one lesson that we learn
from here the briar score again remember
it's zero for the good guy for f1 and
it's a quarter it's big for f2 okay
uh
now what is really this expertise that
i'm talking about expertise is somebody
that recognizes patterns regularities in
the data okay but he knows something and
recognizes that i mean maybe because he
knows somebody told him something about
the process that generates the data or
maybe just looks at the data and finds
patterns you know there are many
patterns there for one reason or another
okay and when you recognize patterns
then what you that allows you to sort
the days into beings such that all the
days that are in the same being they are
very similar okay what happens is
similar that's how you recognize okay
and of course you want to make the
beginning as refined as possible because
putting everything in one being i mean
you have not recognized anything
everything is the same for you okay you
have not identified anything
okay so
expertise is really measured by having a
low refinement score
okay the variance in the bins should be
small means you're succeeding
identifying all those days where there
is very little rain all those days there
is a lot of rain and so on okay
now
as i said calibration can also be
guaranteed
now to guarantee calibration you run
an algorithm like the one i showed you
or some other algorithms as i said there
are many other procedures to do it i
showed one that is extremely simple but
there are many other
calibration procedures calibration
algorithms now if you run a calibration
procedure then and suppose you have some
expertise you know something about the
weather okay you have some information
you have some knowledge you have some
expertise if you use the calibration
algorithm that's lost that's completely
lost okay
so
the question is
can we get calibration
but without losing expertise assuming we
have some expertise can we do that
can we be calibrated but not lose
whatever expertise we have whatever
patterns whatever things we have
observed in the data
can we keep that and gain calibration
okay so in a sense can we get k down to
zero
but without increasing the the inside
the in
inside bean variance the r okay
or let me let me
study that differently
can we take b the prior score and
decrease it by k
okay
that means bringing k to zero okay
so uh
sure we can do this very easily okay uh
what you can do is
take
take any any beam look at the average of
the b
and if the average of the beam is not
equal to what the what the fork what the
forecast that generated that beam then
we can just just change all the
forecasts
for that
uh
so
we take a beam let's say the 70 b okay
and you observe that the average in that
bin is not 70
but it's 40
so we say okay every time we said 70 we
should replace it by 40
of course
what this does immediately it makes the
calibration equal to zero
because now we really are stating the
average of the beam okay
we are not changing the variance inside
the beam because the variance inside the
beam is the the variance of what
happened in those days it's nothing to
do with the forecast has to do only with
what happened in those days whether
there was rain or no rain that generated
a certain variance we have not touched
that okay
now of course all this we can only do in
retrospect okay what uh what is called
offline okay
we can do it only retrospect say wait a
minute every time i said 70 no no i
meant 40
okay correct it backwards okay now
that's of course not allowed
so the question is can one do it online
okay
so can you make this correction online
okay now the the
uh okay so so just to make sure that
that the game that we are playing is
well defined so we have a certain
forecasting sequence bt
okay
so b b sub t is the forecast that is
given to us by some forecaster okay
and it's the forecaster that we want to
beat okay we want to improve that's why
it's called b or if you want it's the
bet forecaster forecasters are going to
improve so whatever reason you want for
the letter b okay we are going to
generate a new forecast that we call it
ct so c sub t is our forecast
has to be online which means
to generate the forecast ct we are only
allowed to use the forecast of the other
guy and of course the history
not anything about the future
okay and what we want is that the briar
score of our sequence c
should be lower than the prior score of
the sequence b by at least the
calibration score of b
so essentially we have now of course
when i say something like this what i
mean is that you put out the substitute
t and you say this happens
uh up to some error that goes to zero s
t goes to infinity and you want is this
to be done uniformly overall sequences a
t and b t those are technicalities that
you know
i guess everybody in the audience if we
work in this area you know them but i'm
just ignoring them for the moment okay
so we want our prior score to be lower
than the brighter score of the other
sequence by this calibration score
okay
so our prime score is going to be less
than the refinement score of the other
guy because b minus k is exactly r
okay so what we call this is that we are
beating
b
by b's calibration score and because
this kali beating kali beating is
beating someone by by his own
calibration score lowering his briar
score by
an amount that equals to his calibration
score
our price score is going to be lower
than his not just lower but lower by an
amount equal to his calibration
score okay
in the long run
and we want to guarantee this for all
sequences okay
so uh
just for a simple example if somebody
just to make it
clearer uh
let's go back to our rain one zero one
zero suppose the forecast was eighty
percent forty percent eighty percent
forty percent uh you can easily compute
the calibration score of this guy is 0.1
because sometimes he has an error okay i
mean
computation doesn't matter okay so briar
score is 0.1 uh
the refinement score is zero because all
his beans are uniform all the beans when
he said eighty percent there was rain so
there is no variance there all the beans
oh sorry all the days that are in the
eighty percent being
uh there were rainy days no values all
the days when he said 40 percent
uh
no rain no values okay so how do we
correct this well we clearly correct it
by replacing eighty percent with a
hundred percent and forty percent zero
percent but that is done offline okay
so that's very easy to do for in such a
simple example the question is how do we
do it
when
uh we have a general non-stationary
situation it's not rain no rain rain or
rain this kind of very nice alternating
pattern but it's an arbitrary weather
remember even adversarial okay
so the weather is arbitrary it's not
stationary the forecast b are arbitrary
there is no regularity there the
beginning of is not perfect as it was in
the example
the been average don't have to converge
which means you know maybe that if i
after 100 days the the bean of the 40
percent was 60 percent rain and after
200 days it's now 30 percent rain so
these things may fluctuate there is no
reason for those to converge
okay
and you have to do it online and we have
to guarantee it even against an
anniversary okay can we do that
answer yes
now
if you work in this area perhaps you are
probably not surprised by this result
but i hope that you'll be surprised by
how simple it is to do it there is a
very simple way to do it yes by the way
original proof was you know five pages
with taking some algorithm and modifying
and doing that and so on and then he
said wait a minute i mean it can't be so
complicated there must be a year okay
and we started looking at it and in the
end we found really a very simple way to
do it here is a simple way to do it okay
here's the procedure
it's a procedure that guarantees no
matter what the weather will be no
matter what the forecast there will be
that we are going to beat that forecast
the b forecast by at least its
calibration score okay and what you do
is the following so here is the formula
and here is inwards
i'm now at time t small t
okay
and i'm looking at the beam and i'm
looking at the forecast b sub t which is
the forecast of the other guy
and i'm looking at the beam
corresponding to that forecast and i'm
looking what is the current average
of that beam what is the frequency of
rain in that b of course up to yesterday
i still don't know what's going to
happen today
that's going to be my focus
okay
okay so c sub t my forecast at time t
is a bar
at time t minus 1
of the bin corresponding to the current
forecast of the big guy
that's it that works
okay and i'll give you a proof
uh
let's see i i i have about 10 minutes
right i think i started
i started okay seven minutes or
something okay i uh i want to show the
proof it's so simple but it's neat and
it has something to eat okay so here's
the proof so let's start with the
formula for variance
this is the formula for variance you
take x1 up to x
and this is the formula for the variance
and let me and here is a different way
of writing this formula which which i
guess
many of you perhaps all of you have not
seen yet
well i didn't know it before i started
playing with it okay so notice that the
difference between the two formulas is
in the in the
original one we look at the distances
from x bar t which is the average after
period capital t periods
in the second formula we look at the
average we look at the distance from x
bar t minus one which is the average up
to the previous period okay those two
things by the way if you want a nice
exercise prove it okay it's an it it's a
neat exercise to prove it it's not
something difficult of course once you
see it but it's nice
so
what it says is that if we ignore the
one over t factor which we put in red
then we will get we we can ignore that
because it's summation of one over t
divided by one over capital t which is
like log t over t so that goes to zero
is t goes to infinity yes so it's small
o of one so you can ignore that
and if we ignore that then again
we get this thing that the variance is
approximately this expression which you
are going to call the online variance
that looks like the variance except
instead of subtracting or instead
looking the distance from xc to the
average
at the end you look to
the distance between xt and the average
up to yesterday
okay so let's call this the online
variance and the difference between the
variance and the online variance goes to
zero as capital t goes to infinity
assuming that all the x's are bounded
okay
now if that is true for the values since
refinement is really the
the average of the variances in all the
beans then we are going to get the same
thing okay and
i'll just write the formula if you
remember the formula for r you have to
subtract from a the average of the b and
capital t instead you now subtract from
a the average of the beam at time t
minus one in the previous period so
that's it okay
now what does our procedure do our
procedure takes exactly this okay let me
see
if i can
something happen to my screen
i don't know but let me try
okay this thing here
is exactly our forecast
okay so this is really
the brighter score of my focus because
the distance between 80 and ct ct is
exactly a bar t minus one of bt
okay so what we got is
that rb is bc
minus something that goes to zero okay
that's it end of proof
that's a whole proof
okay
very good so now uh
let's go one more step
okay so we know how to calibri okay
that's a way to calibrate
okay you your forecast
the average up to now of
the other guy's forecast of the beam of
the other guy's beam
according to the for the forecast that
he's going to use now so if he's going
to say 70
we are going to look at his 70 beam
look at the average the frequency of
rain that we had up to yesterday in the
70 percent beam of his
in the beam of his 70 forecast we are
locked and we are going to focus exactly
that that's it
it works
now let's let's uh let's uh try to do
the foreign thing suppose i want to
calibrate myself i want to do self
calibity okay it's not a new religion
don't worry it's uh but let's see what
it says so self calibuting means
let me give a forecast ct which exactly
equals
to a bar t minus 1 of ct
well if we can do that what are going to
do that means the b and c are the same
okay i'm beating myself i'm curry
beating myself then we're going to get
so we replace b by c everywhere we are
going to get b
the brighter score of c less than or
equal to the brighter score of c minus
the calibration score of c okay which is
exactly equivalent to saying that the
calibration score of c is zero
so self-calibrating is calibrating
we just get a calibrated procedure
okay
so self-calibrity exactly makes
calibration score equals zero
question is how do we get ct equal or
even close to about t minus one of ct
sorry look a bar t minus one is a
function
that mets forecast
to the average up to yesterday of the
being corresponding to that forecast
it's an arbitrary function in fact of
those dots in the graph that i showed
you okay that they can be anywhere okay
so what we are trying to find is a fixed
point a point that is on the diagonal of
that graph
if it's one dimension if it's
multi-dimensional then of course it's a
fixed point in in rd for a general
dimensional space for a general
d-dimensional space yes how do we do
that
well if the function would be continuous
then of course brow fix pointer and
gives us a fixed point but there is no
reason for this to be continuous so how
do we do that we cannot can we find
perhaps an approximate fixed point no
because again think of a function that
you know is one up to one half and zero
from one half on
okay and remember you want to be on the
diagonal i mean there is nothing close
to the angle there is no approximate
fixed point okay there is nothing that
is even close to being a fixed point
okay
uh
so
we do something else okay so here is the
result which we call it the stochastic
fixed point it says the following there
is a probability distribution over
forecast
okay
such that
uh if i
z the expression written here is correct
okay now what does this mean
okay
um
sorry one second i'm still
oops
okay uh let me try now again so uh if c
and g of c were equal
if i had a fixed point then this
expression would be zero so i'm looking
at this expression and i want it to be
small no matter what x in c i'm taking
okay so it turns out that i can always
find not a point c such that this is
true because finding a point c such as
this is true essentially says a fixed
point
okay
but i can find the probability
distribution over point c such that on
average this thing is small is less or
equal say delta square
okay
uh now how do we prove such a such a
thing
okay here are the assumptions on c
compact convex whatever for uh g is an
arbitrary function it's important it's
an arbitrary function completely
arbitrary okay make no assumption on the
function now this net result is a
minimum experiment okay if you want
solve a linear programming problem okay
but i like to think of it as a minimax
problem
okay so that's a stochastic fixed point
uh that's something that in our previous
paper on forecast hedging we called it
an outgoing mini max
and if you want more on that look in our
previous paper look in our current paper
uh there's an appendix that discusses
this it's a very useful tool okay and
has to do with hedging what they call
forecast hedging and it's uh it's a very
nice tool
okay let's forget that so
the result that we get and i i'm
finishing just two more slides and i'm
finishing yes i'm sorry that i'm
i i was too slow in the beginning so if
we apply
sorry i said no problem
yeah okay um
so
the result is that if we apply this
outgoing term or this stochastic fixed
pointer and i said we can generate a
procedure that gives us calibration in
fact that's one of the standard
procedures for calibration okay it's not
something new but it's nice to think of
calibration as self calibity
okay
so you just do self calibuting plus
outgoing mini max and you get
calibration
now
uh
how about the following thing supposedly
beat somebody so we lowered the brighter
score by his calibration score our
calibre our prior score is lower than
his by his calibration score
does it mean that we are calibrated no
so somebody can kind of beat us right
okay you know we can get now somebody
called eating curry beating and so on so
you get can get this infinite regress
okay we should stop it how do we stop it
by making sure not only did cali beat
somebody but we ourselves are calibrated
can we do that
answer yes very easy what we do we apply
our contributing procedure to the joint
beginning
of what the other guy says and what we
say
plus the outgoing mini maps
or the stochastic fixed point theorem
that i mentioned okay so there exists a
stochastic procedure that's guaranteed
and itself calibrated
okay
finally suppose we have many
forecasters
okay we can beat them all we can
calibrate them all and moreover it can
be calibrated okay so there exists
moreover
um
sorry uh
sorry
let's look at this result um
there exists a stochastic procedure that
guarantees simultaneously beating of
several forecasters and
that you yourself are calibrated
now
uh
there isn't there is a stronger notion
sorry there is a weaker notion of
calibration
uh called weak calibration uh
also smooth calibration uh has to do
with smoothing out the calibration score
okay now there are variants of that that
have been proposed in the literature uh
mainly by dean foster and sham champ
arcade and
and
in our previous paper
we think we we we have cleaned that up
and we have another notion that we call
continuous calibration that it's much
more
clean and easy to work with that that is
stronger i mean that implies all the
previous versions
and
the beauty about continuous calibration
so continuous calibration is like
calibration except you smooth out the
score okay i i'm not going to get into
the test because i'm out of time but the
beauty of that is that you can get that
with a deterministic procedure
okay so
if you want to uh
what is my sorry okay uh i think here
i'm missing something
uh
yeah uh okay uh
so if we what i meant there is
continuous calibration okay so if we
move to continuous calibration we can do
it deterministically okay and just to
make sure
uh if you work
with uh
the minimax term which is linear
programming and its polynomial kind of
of method then your procedures are going
to be stochastic
if you want to get continuous
calibration
you need to solve fixed point problems
which is much harder of course
but the payoff is that you are going to
get deterministic procedures okay and
that's very important for gate for game
dynamics for example see my talk of uh
you know my my talk in the previous
session of this
of this conference okay and that's it
i'm done sorry that i'm gone over i just
thought that i'll finish with uh
uh
[Music]
some announcement on on successful
economic forecasting i don't know if
you've seen it but some
taking pride in our echo
correctly forecasted eight of the last
five recessions okay and it's a joke
somebody took me seriously and didn't
understand that so thank you
i don't know if there are any questions
everything was clear everything was
unclear
yeah were there any questions in this
room
um i can ask a quick question so i guess
like the the uh the basic kind of like
decomposition you showed uh was kind of
using the fact that you're working with
like squared error or i guess more
generally this would probably work with
like the euclidean norm
um i guess just a basic question is like
uh whether you can do something similar
for like i guess more general loss
functions like maybe if you have like a
bregman divergence or something like
this well if it's decomposable so
bregman divergences also have their own
decompositions so yeah it can be
composed neatly yes but
it's uh
so for example you try to do it with the
l1 norm it won't work but you always
know that that if you want to get it
from the end to know so you do the
composition from the ear to know then
whatever you get from that to norm you
know you get bounced on the l1 norm for
each one of the terms separately that's
the best way to proceed yes so you find
a way where this is orthogonal which is
usually the l2 and then that's your
starting point for the decomposition
then you know
what whatever nice properties you get
for the l2 norm of course they transfer
to any other node
that's what i
yeah
but again if you are
there are some certainties there i must
say you know if you worry about bounds
exactly and so on then uh
then
one may think they all work and you know
it's uh some things work neatly was
there one norm something's what neatly
was there too normal and when you go to
until you lose something
but
that's not yeah no that makes sense for
sure
let's see are there any other questions
in this room
um you said a little bit at the end
about calibrating with respect to um
multiple uh
well expert forecasters um i'm curious
about whether you can
in any circumstances get a caliber
beating result with respect to a
continuum of forecasters but something
that may be well behaved maybe it's a
convex set or something
look if it's a nice convex set and you
you in some sense you you beat the
extreme points i mean you probably
can beat the averages i don't know i
mean again it depends on what's the
linear structure there yes exactly uh
but no i i haven't thought about the
continuum of forecasters uh but where do
you have a continuum of forecasters
no i mean
it's uh
again it's uh
there are probably technical problems
doing that i don't know but uh
conceptually i mean i don't see a
problem but technically i'm sure there
will be problems trying to do that
i should also say that that our
procedure
uh so the strength taking our method
which is really
uh
you look at the joint meaning of all the
forecasters so you know
you have one bean for when forecaster
one said twenty percent and forecaster
two sits thirty percent and orchestra
city said fifty percent that's one b
when forecaster wants a twenty this uh
thirty for the second
uh seventy for the sub it's another b so
so the number of beans increases
increases as the product
of the number of individual beans and
that's not good okay
so our procedure works but in terms of
our test is not good so in the appendix
in our paper we have
another way of doing it uh
which which gets a stiller lobe t over t
error
okay without without increasing
exponentially in the number of
orchestras which is a danger
okay
and that may be useful if you want to go
to say continue okay
so the simple way of doing it the
extension of that is when you have many
may become problematic in terms of the
error terms very interesting i look
forward to checking that out thank you
yeah so as i said look at the paper i
think it's uh we have it uh well uh
well
well done there
or if you find it out let us know you
know or anything that is not clear we
will be happy to hear about it yeah
i think we've got one more question
yeah so um maybe let me ask uh
somewhat of a philosophical question so
i really like this work you know as well
as you know the sequence of works that
preceded this one
um and i think this is
you know
this cali beating concept um is
kind of you know one last piece of
evidence
um
that kind of demonstrates that
calibration you know is something that
you know
in many many circumstances we can
basically get like four free
quote-unquote if we wanted
right and
in this in this particular
case this decomposition shows some sort
of orthogonality um between um
some notion of expertise and you know
just having calibration and so clearly
you know from from a human point of view
um you know having calibration um you
know means that you know you can tell
people look you know when i say this uh
that's what actually happens
um
but
what do you think about the usefulness
of calibration you know just
beyond uh sort of wrapping your
predictor which may already be like
powerful and refined and accurate um you
know into this nicer form so
what what uh is
the significance of calibration beyond
that
look
in some sense you said it yes i mean
since calibration you can get it for
free i mean if you're not calibrated i
mean something is wrong with you yes i
mean
i mean generating
forecasts that are not calibrated that's
that's plain stupid i mean
so again
after these results you could say look i
can be calibrated but then i'm losing on
my expertise now i show we show you that
you can keep whatever expertise you have
and also get calibration okay so why not
okay uh by the way the forecasts are
going to be different the beginning that
i generate with that we generate is
different than the beginning that you
generated okay so so it changes the
thing but it preserves the the if the
variance was small if the refinement
scores more it's preserved okay so
that's that's a good thing so the
expertise is preserved
now uh
is so
again at the general level what is
calibration useful why do we care about
calibration besides the fact that you
know it's a nice property okay so i'll
tell you a story
uh
about uh about a certain very big
company that uh was using some calibre
some some forecasting procedure to know
exactly what is going to be the demand
for next months you know in order to
know how much to put in in storage you
know
[Music]
something of that sort okay they had to
then to plan
to plan how much to order each month
and they were focusing the demand okay
now somebody somebody looked at it and
said wait a minute i mean this
forecaster i'm not calibrated okay i
mean they are completely off of mark uh
so
uh
in fact and looking the historical data
there is a very easy way to there is a
very easy way to improve them not not to
get them calibrated but very simple just
multiply them by 0.7 and you are getting
something that is almost calibrated much
much better okay
so uh succeeding convincing the the
management of the company
and the company very happily you know
at some point switched you know just use
the same algorithm but multiply the
result by 0.7 okay
well they expected well now we are going
to get much better since our focus is
calibrated much better than before we
are going to make much more money we are
not going to have extra
extra
uh
extra supply in our warehouses and so on
turns out they started losing money okay
what happened well what happened was
something very simple
the guys that were managing the storage
they realized that the forecasts were
not calibrated and in fact they knew
that if the forecast comes as a hundred
they should not order more than 70. okay
now when the forecast came 70 they
ordered only 49.
so they were short okay so there's a
miscommunication so uh
in fact we discussed this if you want
read our paper in jp our previous paper
in jp just appeared last year on
forecast hedging we have a section uh
that we call the economic value of
calibration
and and this and
forecasts that are calibrated
uh decouple in some sense the
forecasting
part from the decision-making part you
don't have to know how the forecast will
arrive that you don't have to know what
they are if they are calibrated you take
them at face value
and you make the decision given the
forecast which is really the right
frequency okay
uh now that's true for example for game
dynamics but it's also really real life
okay if the forecasts are calibrated
then you don't have to to start saying
yes but you have to multiply by 0.7 or
things like that okay
so you know exactly what they mean and
you don't care where they come from so
there is a big advantage to having
calibrated forecasts for decision making
okay
i don't know that that answers your
question but uh
perhaps looking in our paper there we
have a couple of pages discussing this
perhaps you know something will strike
you as relevant
thank you yeah this was an amusing story
yeah it's a true story by the way it's a
true story i know the person was
involved
i won't say which company it was
all right um i think we'll stop there
and uh go to the next break uh we'll be
back at 10 15 for the next talk
uh but yeah so let's uh let's give
another round of applause for sergio
that was uh that was really fun talk and
we're really glad you could join us
yeah thank you thank you
thanks again
you